وللقرون عديده احسنت تعرف يعني انت تعرف
انه الاديان الابراهيميه كلها هذه هذا كان
واحد من الاجنده انه يفشى السلام بين
الناس يعني عرفت بدون اي تميز هذه واحده
الامر الاخر يعني
دائما دائما هو كان وجه لطبيعه الصراع
الموجود في في المنطقه يعني عرفت اللي هو
اسرع
الابعاد اثنيه وعراقيه
واثنيه وعرقيه بالضروره جدليه تعني انه
يعني سرديه اللون هذه عرفت
والدماء الزنجيه والدماء العروبيه لا يعرف
بعض المشاهدين العرب انه داخل السودان في
تمييز لوني حتى داخل السعوديه يعني تمييز
عنصري ايوه وجزء برضو وجهه للنزاع والصراع
هذا الامر يعني شفته لمن مطلقا في لحظه من
اللحظات التاريخ من هذا الاشتباك يعني من
البنيه الاثريه
والقبليه ان شئت يعني والعرقيه
وكان عندها تجلياتها طبعا بالتاكيد مثلا
انت لو اخدت عنصر واحد اللي هو
تشكيل دوله وطنيه نيشان
دائما هذه الجغرافيا كانت تعجز عن هذا
الامر وهذا الامر مرتبط بتجارب في ظني
بالتجارب الاستعمار ليش في واحد اللي هو
كرومر اللورد كرومر معروف هو كان مهندس
الاستعمار البريطاني او الكولونياليه
البريطانيه
هذا الرجل لما راى من من حضور البنيه
الاثنيه وشاف الاشتباكات والنزاعات
القبليه من من منذ فجر التاريخ قال وصيه
الوحيده هذا في كتابه معروف اسمه مصر
الحديثه عرفت في بضعه مجلدات وكان نصيب
السودان منها كبير يعني اللورد كرومر قال
مما شاهدته
ينبغي على اهل هذه البلد ان يفكروا في
حكومه حقيقيه وليست قوميه او وطني لانه
شهد الرجل لسنوات حكومه عمليه يعني
حقيقيه هو قال ريال كفر من رمضان
يعني ناشونال لانه شاف انه ما راح يكون في
على الاطلاق تجانس وهذا الصراع والاشتباك
اللي جذره قبلي وعرقي